just wishing everybody a really nice  monday i hope everybody's super well  if your family's healthy hope you're  good i'm trying to send you some good  positivity hope something really fun  happens today  something unexpected  keep your eyes open for the unexpected i  think a lot of people  suppress their curiosity  just kind of go through the motions and  miss little things that can  change your world let a tick tock or a  tweet that i put out send them down a  web 3 nft path  and how much impact that's had and now  they have their own projects  run  nftpr firms have done really well in  investing or whatever it is and i think  about the millions of times a day that's  happening  where other people in science or other  places food or  technology are  making content and  putting it out there in the world and  allowing people to  to change their life so being into  curiosity say maybe instead of no and  see where that takes you